[Music]
in the 80s when lots of people were
playing arcade games like pac-man Donkey
Kong and Frogger this is what they were
playing in Soviet Russia this product of
pitied is to reach my field of Robotics
carotids that's Alexander
he runs the Museum of Soviet arcade
machines in Saint Petersburg Russia
[Music]
hadiyyah-lah museum but still poacher
endorsed hasta XIV escape mania spa
Misha Kotik after matters of Pascale's
not answered any of this Minnesota
fresco is on us from the Shabbat vaccine
the fettuccine in Moscow which
disinvited unlike their Western
counterparts the games weren't just for
fun stoic Israel's logic of cellular
automata witnessed the only puppeteer
still automatic at or near its current
across look out the point of the games
was training for the Soviet Army
building skills like reasoning and eye
coordination and marksmanship sameness
of data 1/4 size comparison actually
opus category of time I will sit down
with an emotionally Sammi popular
estimate Nemo group really is stubborn
electronica fight Messiah stamatis me at
my medium ischemia tow cable siren
awareness pollution McGraw conney
all the Soviet arcade games were built
in military factories using leftover
parts from weapons refrigerators
calculators and other items they still
apportioned like usual indicating these
parts even
receipt a stroke or even estimate estoy
vacío Miriah prosna mulch Qaddafi ironic
resist criminal severe skin really
but now decades after the fall of the
Soviet Union Street near a bionic
facility National Museum provided movie
a villa Collier on near the sea route
CBS service team soluz on you pristine
serious Congrats
[Music]
[Music]
Tetris it transcends age culture and
language it's a gamer and non-gamers
game but did you know Tetris has a
Soviet past Tetris is the brainchild of
this man Alexey Pajitnov
Alexey was a computer programmer in
Russia he worked for the Soviet Union at
the Moscow Academy of Sciences Alexey
always had a propensity for math
computers and puzzles it was that
propensity that led him to the creation
of the best video game of all time he
drew inspiration from a little-known
game pentominoes pentominoes was a
puzzle board game in which you had to
fit geometric shapes together Alexey
took the principles from pentominoes
upgraded them and created a computer
game originally only intended for
himself he named the game Tetris for two
reasons it's a combination of tetra the
Greek word meaning for and tennis [ __ ]
nafse favorite sport because Tetris was
created during work hours the Soviet
Union claimed all rights to both Tetris
and all royalties boy fast forward to
1996 the rights of tetris was finally
signed over to positon off tetris taps
into our universal need to create order
out of chaos which is ultimately why
it's one of the most iconic games in
history
[Music]
[Music]
this here is a darkling beetle it lives
out here in the vast desert of Northwest
Utah and he's on the move way or - I
don't have a clue but I can tell you
about the town he's leaving behind
welcome to loosen Utah there's abandoned
cars weeds once in a while
train will pass through yep there's not
a whole lot here and loosen well except
for this man but who is this man this
man who lives in an airplane hangar who
flies a Cessna to get to his closest
friends who is this man this man who
lives in the middle of nowhere who lives
25 miles from this bar with this man
inside who owns a bunch of guns works
with machines made this thing
is this man my name is Ivo not ask a and
this is what I live as you've gathered
this man isn't from around loosen he
grew up in Czechoslovakia before the
fall of the USSR he didn't like it much
it's kinda hard to do anything the
Communists were in power is there you
cannot have your own business it's kind
of difficult to fly there so high Khanna
I didn't feel like I could be myself he
really wanted to leave the country but
it wasn't easy
there was an Iron Curtain they like have
a machine gun towers and barbed wire to
keep you in they like to keep you so
when he was 24 he escaped the country
the only way he knew how
by flying across the border in his self
built airplane so I drove up close to
the border between Austria and some time
like at 3 o'clock in the morning I took
off and I just got it over to Austria
and I found myself Vienna International
Airport and I landed that and then I
just showed them my expired passports
and I asked for asylum and the world
took nervous
[Music]
I guess they're never seen on this thing
like that before word it so I think they
liked it I liked it I though then moved
to Los Angeles and built up a successful
airplane propeller business but even LA
couldn't fit his big ideas I kind of
needed a place to test my other idea
which is how to do it in the middle of
the city that's how I found this place
in Utah it was for sales I bought it and
I've been here for like eight years
yeah what was I was big idea that
brought him to loosen well it's behind
that door over there
[Music]
inside sits in a propeller flying
machine able to lift off and land
vertically it's basically an airplane
helicopter hybrid of sorts it's kind of
funny-looking but the damn thing
actually flies
[Music]
so what's Ava's next big project the
solar-powered aircraft an innovative
propeller design some kind of new way to
fly the next big one is that the
speargun idea which actually it was
better than I thought that doesn't
always work that way sometimes I get the
really bad ideas
[Music]
even while inventing new spear guns and
the like Ivo still finds the time to get
out of the house in fact that's him over
there hiking on the side of a mountain
it's just him nature and his customized
rifle
I think the gun was mean because of the
mountain lions
however treacherous the hike it's always
worth it you get a good view of loosen
it actually looks pretty nice from here
don't it you know I still wonder why did
that Darkman beetle ever leave this
place maybe loosen wasn't right for the
little guy
maybe it's escaped into the next place
where it can be itself farrago though
looks like this might be his last stop
can I realize that this is what I always
wanted I kept escaping until I skipped
to listen and now I don't have anywhere
else to escape like not a study here
[Music]
well no it's also a truce if you think
about it
[Music]
chapter one he adored Las Vegas a city
that looked as beautiful as him no no no
no that's too narcissistic let me start
this over to him Las Vegas was a city
full of color energy and opportunity a
complete contrast from where he came
from this is the story of how Daniel pol
escaped the clutches of the Iron Curtain
on its zip line and won his freedom yeah
this sounds much better
[Music]
hold on let's pause for a second to
understand this story we need to go back
like way back like back to the 80s
the place is Czechoslovakia the ruling
party communists our character is Daniel
pol a young man who was politically
outspoken people that knew me really
well they told me hey listen all I can
tell you is you really want to tone it
down Tommy a political speech because uh
he wound up in prison and that's when I
started plotting escape while planning
his exit strategy Daniel made another
radical thinker a physicist named Robert
Oz whoa Robert was pretty well gifted
when I came to physics he was imprisoned
for political reasons so I knew that
this guy's crazy enough to be my partner
in crime to get out with we tried to
come up with all kinds of crazy ideas
like building our own rockets and flying
over the Iron Curtain digging tunnels
none of it seemed viable for many
reasons
then one day Leslie Robert glancing in a
power line and something told me you
should be worried he says we're gonna
zipline into Austria I said no do you
clinically insane and he says and that's
what are we gonna get out so the two got
to work and over the next several months
they built and tested their own police
the plan was to infiltrate the border
zone climb up the tower set up the
police zipline over the Iron Curtain
climb down from the next power into
no-man's land and then make it into
Austria the reason why this was so
insanely dangerous because we could have
gotten shot at the border could have
gotten electrocuted could have gotten
torn apart by border dogs and then you
have 380 thousand volts coursing
underneath your feet
yeah this mission was to put it mildly
extremely dangerous it was almost like a
mission impossible but that didn't stop
these two with their pulleys made and
their plan in place they headed out and
climbed the tower
Robert won first and when he took off my
heart just sunk and I was like yeah
there is no turning back I am doing this
I just I decided to go for it I went for
it
when I was a zip lining it was like
mixture of emotions you never
experienced before
you are way up high you have a lot of
electricity around you that was crazy
but despite all the close calls we made
it Daniel and Robert became local
celebrities appearing in news outlets
all over Europe Daniel even donated his
pulley to the Checkpoint Charlie Museum
in Berlin the pulley still hangs there
today
Robert remained in Austria but Daniel
his sights were on America so he moved
to the one place that could match his
personality Vegas so wrote a book I got
married draw the cab in Vegas I don't
think I would rather cab anywhere else
but in Vegas it's fun very international
City very dynamic it's awesome I want it
to be free at 12 yes I wanted to piss
all the comics I wanted to show them
that doesn't matter what our incursion
what wall they're gonna build how many
Border Patrol guards they're gonna place
on the border I'm still getting through
they cannot defeat the human spirit that
once it
[Music]